okay here i am in my own kitchen
filming myself which is weird my name is
andrew you might recognize me from the
show
worth it eating foods at different price
points with my pals steven and adam
or from the show eating your feed where
adam the same adam
challenges me to recreate foods from the
internet
and today i'm going to be doing a little
bit of both today i'm going to be
recreating
one of my favorite dishes from worth it
vinegar pie
wait you guys never ate vinegar pie some
of you savvy or viewers
might say in our pie episode at our
second location
underbelly we're mainly eating this
delicious carrot cake
hand pie the restaurant actually had a
few other pies on the menu that they
wanted us to try
this is the one that adam is giddily
poking at with his fork
super delicious and explores a thing
that i'm really obsessed with which is
the fundamentals of why something tastes
good
vinegar pie holy [ __ ] doesn't sound like
it should taste good
and yet this version was extremely
delicious
to get a little more background on this
dish i'm going to be speaking with
victoria dearman from
underbelly about how it's made where it
came from
and how how does it taste good
and why ah i want to see my big frying
pan
hey victoria thanks for chatting with me
hey yeah thanks andrew good to see you
again
everybody that i brought up this recipe
to is like what kind of pie
a what pie nine years of my life
hearing a what type yeah every person
that
came in thunderbelly there were two
things their server told them to get
korean goat and dumpling and it was the
vinegar pot and there's a lot of people
that are like
man this thing is so weird just so good
but so good
yeah well i'll actually show you where i
got the inspiration for it it's called
hillbilly cooking jessica shepard got
from maybe a garage sale
he just writes yep and yes the recipe
itself is
up to translation i guess a nubbin of
butter i made it at first with
straight distilled vinegar oh
interesting not good
so the whole point of it is it's a pie
that you can make when citrus is an
infuser so i use
steamed sugarcane vinegar and korean
double strength apple vinegar are you
willing to share more of the recipe with
me for me to recreate it or is it more
of a secret
it's actually in chris's book that came
out honestly confession
it was probably my favorite pie i ate in
the entire video
not not about that confession thanks for
chatting and i'll let you know how it
goes send me a picture can't wait to see
it
all right bye so it's another day i've
got
the exact korean apple vinegar i wasn't
able to get that second vinegar but i
was following the underbelly recipe from
their cookbook that used entirely just
apple cider vinegar and since i'm
exploring taste
why not do a side-by-side taste test
with my
american apple cider vinegar is that
weird
maybe i regret this decision just just
the smallest of tastes
[Music]
yeah very vinegary also incredibly
appley by comparison this is bragg's
much more like fermenty kombucha like
while this one tastes like an apple sour
candy
that's great but i have the exact
vinegar i need it's on to make the crust
so in the underbelly book it recommends
using a hand mixer
i don't have a hand mixer but i do have
a stand mixer
as you can see i don't have adam here
follow me along so i'm moving the camera
i didn't realize how annoying that would
be
i'm going to put it in some plastic wrap
and leave it in the fridge
it's been 30 minutes the dough is chill
it's time to put it
in my tart pan i'm gonna grab
some flour for my surface that is a
uh a soft blob this feels incredibly
fragile
and now i'm going to do the thing that
i've only watched
other people ever do to try gently
rolling
this up this is i can already tell this
is a
huge mistake and then unrolling it
my dough is not a circle so i'm filling
in the cracks
and crevices this looks like crap i know
i know what you're saying you're not
wrong
next i have parchment into which i will
pour
old beans to weigh down the crust
i'm now going to put this in the oven
for 15 minutes
okay it's been about 15 minutes time to
check on the pie
and remove the beans it doesn't look
done but it doesn't
look terrible that could turn into a pie
10 more minutes
it's been 10 minutes uh
i i don't i don't know this looks like
it doesn't want to get any darker so i'm
calling it there
the next step is to make the filling
and that's when the vinegar comes into
play
i am not a very well seasoned baker what
are the things i'm gonna mess up so
that's the best part about this pie
meaning the words every time you make it
is totally different okay so the biggest
thing you want to watch out for
is that it is a corn starch space so you
do have to boil it like you gotta go for
three ish minutes and what happens if
you don't do that
it'll be soup oh interesting well maybe
i'll invent vinegar soup
if things don't go well so starting off
four eggs two cups of sugar
which i mean i guess desserts just have
a lot of sugar
but i am i don't know a little surprise
whisking this together until there are
no
more clumps the magic ingredient part
one quarter
cup two cups of water yeah this pan is
definitely not large enough oh well
lemon juice salt corn starch
okay so now bring this to a boil
whisking constantly
not realize how stressful baking was i
think this needs to like achieve
the boil because that's what the
instructions say but it also says whisk
constantly
i mean this is medium heat god this is
the most stressful part
of anything it's like the do nothing
like i'm used to failing on eating your
feet but
failing is a lot less funny when you're
by yourself
are bubbles coming up yeah we got like a
slow burble now
oh it is quite thick now yeah it's like
it's a pot of pudding now
i see some dark bits so now i'm scared
that it's burning on the bottoms but
victoria said boil the crap out of it
jesus it's only been one minute i can't
do this for three minutes
the smell oh you know the smell is not
pleasant currently
okay we're up to two minutes we're
almost there this is the
this is the stress we're right at three
minutes i've got my butter here
i have this vanilla paste okay it seems
to be
all incorporated it's my cooled tart
here we go ready
i have a little bit of excess here
because i'm actually
[Music]
oh oh the last instruction takes some
plastic wrap directly onto the surface
so that it doesn't form a skin
because this has to go in the
refrigerator now overnight
forgot that there was a uh separated
bottom on the bottom of this
one more quick wrap i think i'm going to
call that a pie that's ready for the
fridge
so here we are pie has been in the oven
uh not the oven the pie has been in the
refrigerator overnight
it looks like a pie but there's one more
element that i want to recreate the
caramel
brittle this is not in the underbelly
cookbook but this is the way that i had
it at the restaurant
so here we go one cup of sugar a quarter
cup of water
and now i'm turning it on like medium i
don't know i've never done this before
i think you're not supposed to stir it
but i want to stir it because i can see
where the sugar is
it's kind of pushed away from the
bubbles okay it's now a nice
even bubbleage bubbles are trippy like a
miyazaki movie
where every bubble is a little creature
trying to
eat the air suddenly smelling very
caramelly i'm at around 3 okay that goes
off
and now i'm gonna pour this on here a
little bit of
salt did i just make caramel that is
freaking
okay it seems firm
i knew i should have done a better job
getting those bubbles out
there has got to be some baker's trick
to get
plastic wrap to be perfectly smooth on
the surface
still pretty vinegary in smell
yeah look at that thing it's a freaking
pie
i'm dying to know how this tastes ooh
uh oh i'm scared it feels very loose
god
hell yeah is this why they say easy as
pie
i the crust for sure look it's got that
that
that wobble the caramel this is a big
sheet of something here it's definitely
screwed up in some way that has this
like cloudiness over it
hurts my teeth so looking at our video
the little shards of brittle are just
cascading
off the side should i just stab a little
piece in
this is my pie i think it's time to try
it
[Music]
doesn't taste terrible it really does it
does not
taste the way that it smells i i don't
know what to call the taste
is this as good as the restaurant's
version it's not no the crust is too
thick i clearly screwed up the caramel
it doesn't taste like a weird wacky
thing
it's just got like enough butter from
the crust mellowness from this vanilla
a sourness that is kind of familiar but
it's still
curious and interesting it's a pretty
good pie i think the only thing i want
to do now
is see if adam wants a slice
oh it smells like vinegar
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
you